du suspense de la violence mais de
l'amour aussi avec comme décor l'afrique
tous les ingrédients pour faire un bon
thriller la constance du jardinier sort
aujourd'hui en salles et risque bien de
crever l'écran
tiré du best-seller de john le carré le
film dénonce les pratiques scandaleuses
du lobby pharmaceutique dans les pays du
tiers monde sur fond de meurtre et
d'intrigués diabolique dominique poncet
et nathalie bertière en afrique les
toits ce film va commencer par une très
belle et très forte histoire d'amour
entre un diplomate passionné par les
plantes et les fleurs et une militante
convaincue de la cause altermondialiste
et puis par un extraordinaire tour de
passe-passe scénaristique
il va nous entraîner dans une enquête
captivante sur la pratique de certains
laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui
utilisent des africains comme cobayes
humains
pourquoi cette femme est repartie elle
refuse le traitement de vouloir un
médicament
ce n'est pas moi qui fais le règlement
tout semble réel et pourtant tout est
fiction avant d'être un film
cette dénonciation des pratiques des
lobbys pharmaceutiques a été imaginée
par john le carré pour les besoins d'un
polar devenu best-seller
tout est fiction donc mais pourtant tout
est inspiré par des pratiques similaires
à celles dénoncées ici et c'est ce
scandale innommable qui a intéressé le
brésilien fernando meirelles
oui à l'afrique c'est loin du brésil
mais le problème avec le temps
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est un
problème près près bull au brésil
le gouvernement brésilien eut
l'industrie pharmaceutique sont 32 su
battre c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
faire ce film
je croyais que c'était intéressant de
faire don king ou pour dénoncer
l'industrie pharmaceutique
il y a une chose pour laquelle je tiens
à remercier le docteur amy d'abba c'est
d'offrir de la névirapine il a persuadé
les labos de faire un geste pour les
mères séropositives
alors on se demandait si mme kuyo net de
+ docteur nkabinde on s'est compris mais
ont-ils été changés ans et une usine
avec laquelle vous êtes venus je vois
que je suis comme ça je ne l'ont pas
réussi l'auteur ce film c'est le récit
d'un voyage à l'intérieur de deux êtres
qui s'aiment et aussi celui de leur père
ce vol pour mieux comprendre le monde à
croire cette adresse votre journal
exactement aux cobayes africains aux
tests bâclés pour vendre un produit
dangereux aux patients contraint
d'accepter leur peur de représailles
contre leurs enfants parce qu'il se fait
l'écho d'une réalité inacceptable parce
qu'il a été tournée au kenya avec l'aide
de ses habitants parce qu'il est lui une
forme stylistique éblouissante elle est
construit comme un thriller
cette constance du jardinier devrait
cette semaine crever tous les écrans